so i've you know i'm not like chris
nolan in many ways
any critic will tell you but one of
those ways is like chris is always like
we need as much money as possible to do
this practically and do it right because
cinema is forever
and i'm the guy coming from indie film
who's just like
that's good enough that'll get the job
done good enough
is the only way i've gotten this far in
my career if i was striving for
perfection
you never even want to see in clerks for
christ's sake fluid clerks it's
absolutely imperfect
but my whole career was predicated on an
absolutely imperfect sloppy first effort
so what did that teach me for the next
10 years of my career i was like
doesn't have to be better than clerks
like if they'll sit through clerks
they'll watch this and because of that i
never really
push myself or have pushed myself every
once in a while there's like
tusk or some sort of but like
visually speaking i kept real
simple it was only after
directing as many years as i have
where you're just like well maybe i can
maybe i can grow maybe i could try
this i've been around long enough like
and i'm not this is not i don't want
them to
just be misread as like i'm bored i
love what i do for a living
but at a certain point and it's like you
know after the first five movies
every movie's a joy to make don't get me
wrong but after the first five movies
it's like
i i know what the experience of movie
making is that's why when podcasting
happened like i've been podcasting for
13 years now we started 2007.
because that was an art form that was
like what
like i don't need millions of dollars i
can just i could invite my
friends over and sit in my office and
smoke weed and chit chat
that's the art form for me so like that
you know
even though at a point where i was like
ah
you know movies like there was a point
where i retired i literally retired
after like red state i was like i'm done
like this is it this last movie i made
i'm good i'll buy it and you really
believed that you were done you were
like i'm this
i did not even in a this kind of
way but i'm just like
you know i got nothing left to say that
was my point i was like you know let a
young person
say some i don't really have that
much you've seen every trick i can do
red state felt like a high water mark
where i'm like this don't look like
nothing i've ever done before if i took
my name off that movie
a single in the world
including my own mother would know that
i made that boot
so at that point i felt like you know
what this is my film school this is my
masterpiece and i don't mean masterpiece
like this is brilliant like a nolan
movie
i mean like you know i was an apprentice
for decade or more
and finally i was like i'm going to
present my masterpiece to see if i can
go up the next level that's how it
worked you had an apprentice working
under a master artist
and then one day the apprentice would be
like
i made my piece my masterpiece and this
for you to judge and tell me whether i
can ascend or not